pia ouais ouais bien alors je vous faire
une interview moralité on a la chance la
lumière
bon est-ce que vous avez déjà piqué dans
le porte-monnaie de votre maman ouais
voilà l'intrigué du long way c'était
pour la fête foraine à côté de chez moi
j'avais piqué maman si tu m'écoutes je
suis désolé fait 30 des cinq franche
toujours ses cinq francs à bas à
l'époque ça va ça représente 1 million
jeu compliqué euros c'est encore plus
dur parce que tous mes copains il allait
ouais super on a quinze prendre un
génial moi j'étais ok et ramzy jamais si
j'ai dû le faire aussi des anecdotes
mais je suis en plus il est vachement
bien peu plus mais un vrai voyage épique
et 500 fans l'anecdote
alors imaginez c'est un jeu de rôle un
vous gagne au loto le billet vous
appartient pas à vous le rendez vous ça
dépend moi honnêtement à grenoble
personnes armées ont des plans d'honneur
personnellement je moi je leur ont
franchement c'est impossible qu'ils
revoient sont épatés termiste non mais
c'est si je vois cette vieille dame dans
la rue tu y as froid
à part ça je reviens interview mensonge
c'était gré m vous êtes déjà sortis et
que la copine d'un copain jamais non
vraiment vous jamais comment ce bar de
moe à la non sérieux jamais vraiment
c'est la honte
par contre moi des copains sont déjà
sortis et que ma copine m'a fait
d'accord
je jure que c'est vrai c'est horrible
c'est dur lick it et iloveyou mal en ce
moment ci n'est qu'un commerçant se
trompe en vous rendant la monnaie vous
lui dites parentis et je lui tends la
même réponse que ce tome i bugzilla
parce que vraiment à des grands
philosophes
je veux dire c'est comme ça c'est la vie
c'est comme ça et mon papa est un
gangster
voilà ok ok sans rien à voir avec la
question
je sais que les systèmes d-box virginie
vient de tourner avec riche et ma cité
va craquer le nouveau film de richesses
ou alors est-ce que vous êtes déjà
fouillé dans le sac de votre copine
jamais est dans le sac de rome 6 bars à
m'sila je trouvais les numéros des hôtes
mais comment et bien sûr on fout ici une
faîtière juillet dans les poches d'eric
pendant qu'il en est mais jamais non
clapet de schaffhouse n'ont pas dans ses
poches dans ce courrier ouais mais pas
assez proche
bon alors je vous faire un cas de
conscience vous êtes propriétaire d'un
appartement
le locataire peut plus payer il a deux
grosses horrible voulait foire des
rameaux c'est horrible pourquoi non pas
comme salon des gosses qui gravent sur
les murs qui es tu vois des corps il
sait que le bordel déchire bon alors
qu'est ce vous faites avec le locataire
vous le verrez vous ne verrez pas si la
de mon pays pas le loyer tout bailly la
demande quand même si le départ qu'ils
sont bien un maxime 1 1
il vise à maximiser content mais il
devait pour différents avis je le vire
pour reviendra à gennevilliers ça
m'avait touché je te jure à
gennevilliers et l'opacité cité du luth
il y avait des mecs qui avait des gens
qui pouvaient pas payer je cherchais les
meilleurs et la mairie communiste qui
avait fait du bien pour eux c'est con ce
que je vais dire ce qu'on avait au
départ le contenu c'est une voix un
souvenir de bagnes est toujours une
bonne idée mais sauf que ça marche
jamais aussi med pour leurrer les
voisins du dessus sont très bien passées
au stade le bonheur ça se construit
aussi jolie ce que tu viens de dire mais
ça aurait pour une phrase passe virginie
ledoyen 5
vous recevez l'ordre du mérite voulait
pas vraiment venu inviter j'ai sauvé un
enfant fait voulait pas vraiment de
soubré ça me fait marrer comme vrai
marin je gardais je fais un long
discours en plus j'ai trouvé détendu
avant l'échangé les circonstances défaut
s'ils recourent d'accueil circonstances
atténuantes
vous trouvez un nourrisson abandonné sur
le paillasson si vous le prenez pas il
va leur folie nakasu fait c'est durant
sa taille ce top durci en plus une
épouse linda la déconnade comme ça
vraiment de quoi la voilà si on réponde
l'enjeu leur envoient leurs fins on
passe quand même pour des reculs et
pourtant c'est ce que moi je passe je
fais comme s'il n'avait pas vu
franchement si c'est comme ça de quoi
monsieur laissez moi je parle je lui
pose trois questions
s'ils répondent correctement que le
ventre es-tu propres
son petit poste de radio transpire
toujours bons souvenirs au courant du
match de foot